pick up jj
your pieces
[Music]
aren't you at you know you're mean and
i'll start with saying by your mean
uh but i figured you'd want to you want
to be on
this one with me oh my yes of course oh
she's back
nice she is back sir she is back back
baggity backpack
first off let me a couple of things here
before we move on to her real quick
would you be the special guest referee
yes okay perfect
i even have the referee shirt the
whistle i have the red and the green
i have i have the whole get up bro
somebody somebody must have worked at a
foot locker
uh i was actually a wrestling ref oh
were you a back backyard wrestling or a
legit resident
high school high school all right
amateur wrestling so we're
okay all right so so did you ever did
you ever uh referee a
brock lesnar match um
no but coincidentally adam hangman page
yes
really yes no [ __ ] adam hangman page
grew up in halifax virginia
and i have not only refereed his matches
as a wrestler but as also a coach
and i i do know him did he win
yes he was he was actually really good
back then now as a coach not so much
because the team suck but that's not his
fault
all right then yes he's just as handsome
and perp
and and you know person as he is there
all right well they for those of you
wondering he's handsome i'm
speaking of a handsome woman uh mayo
heads back
i'll see mayo head is back let's see
what she has to say
okay so i'm about to go back to playing
pokemon we're gonna have an
extra video today um but there's
something that i've
needed to talk about um because
hey frozen just remind me velveteen
dream too oh well there you go look at
you
that was like many years ago though
part of this channel is keeping me
accountable for my health my mental
health
and my physical health i told you all
that i was going to be taking better
care of myself physically this year
and um i've not been doing it
um specifically the past
week i've been eating gluten
now all right you don't know how this
works all right so a little backlog on
the gluten anytime she eats gluten
she gets like violently sick for the
whole week after that
so she gets did she legitimately have a
gluten disease
nothing with her is legitimate but
that's what she says
got it and
i've been feeling the effects from it
slowly
every day i get a little bit sicker a
little bit weaker a little bit
more sore and spend more time in the
bathroom
and i mean look we all know about that
right that looks
i can't i can't i can't begrudge her for
that i know that feeling
it sucks you know part of me doesn't
even understand why i'm doing it
because i i know what happens when i eat
gluten
i know it's making me sick
i know that i could die if i don't stop
because my body needs
nutrients right
i'm i'm aware of this
but my mind keeps telling me that i
deserve gluten
i'm waiting to see how sh when she's
going to blame us for fruiting gluten
disease can lead to heart failure cancer
epilepsy
diabetes and thyroid disease in short if
you have celiac disease gluten can kill
you
hmm jesus learn something new every day
all right jesus to be sick
i deserve to be hurting
i i don't i have to fight it
you know i have to really fight myself
and force myself to
eat things that are healthy and take
care of myself
and
that's hard to do it's
harder to do um at this particular time
of the year because that anniversary
reaction that
i've talked about it before what
anniversary is it the hiv one
i think so i'm not i don't know there's
so many anniversaries of [ __ ]
it's hard to keep up yeah um
the murder happened oh the murder
yeah all right all right so i know what
that one is it was the murderer all
right so
the the first husband uh was dating an
older lady
and she did her little uh
move in and just be a homeless woman uh
living with another you know
um couple and then they decided one
night to murder the old lady and
bury her and she helped
bury the old then why isn't she in jail
for murder
uh the jacksonville police because this
was in jacksonville
obviously determined that it did not
happen
or she wasn't involved enough to charge
her or the other person
but she's admitting to it but yeah she's
admitted to it in
many different forms wait so even the
guy that she says murdered the woman
didn't go to jail
like anyone that's read because again
there's been other people that have
you know given her [ __ ] uh or or trying
to ruin her life or whatever she thinks
they were trying to do
all we're doing is observing her yeah
i'm just watching
yeah um and and no one has found any
like concrete like police reports that
this ever even happened
so i'm i'm x into doubt i'm just saying
my birthday and
it wasn't until five weeks later that i
escaped
and between
you know yesterday and next month
i i i think about it a lot
i i find myself
just back at that time
you know and remembering the days when i
i was tied to a bed
when i was beaten wait
what yes you would find this out if you
uh you get the book
fine but but she was tied to a bed and
beaten
uh tied to a bed beat by not only that
person but several of her family members
as well it's a common thing that she
always gets tied to a bed
sounds more like a movie doesn't it it
is
a little fictional yes when i was
told that i was going to be killed and
buried in a backyard and
all of those nights just
saying that she was going to get the
jenny from forrest grump treatment huh
somebody is going to find me
this living on that hope that
somebody is going to find me
see i don't think she understands how
florida is if you dig
down any further than two feet in
florida you start hitting water there's
water
yeah yeah so you can't really bury
people in florida you can feed them to
gators yeah
burning them is pretty dumb
but nobody ever found me because nobody
was ever looking for me
nobody was ever looking for her either
and nobody went to jail for this no none
that i can find or any of the
captain team awesome autism confined so
and we've done extensive research i
believe you
it it bothers me it bothered me a lot
then
the fact that nobody looked for me
nobody noticed
i was missing you know um
i dropped off the planet for five weeks
and nobody
noticed and
i guess be more memorable would be the
the uh
would you take from this i mean
something
you know maybe have friends that care
don't run them off with your [ __ ]
afterwards
that was like a big part of it was
i often felt like i should have died
because nobody cares
if anybody cared they would have noticed
that i had
been gone and
that's where a lot of the feeling that i
need
that i deserve to hurt and that i
deserve to be sick and that i deserve to
just
let my body waste away um
i still feel that nobody really cares
and nobody's ever going to care and
hey hey mayo head i care never stop
making content please
yes please we don't want you to go
anywhere i want you to be healthy as a
matter of fact
and i know that's wrong because there
are so many of you that do care
and and it's about half an hour is she
borderline
uh i know she has a bunch of diseases
diabetic
part of the lyme person personality oh
uh
i've seen a couple i'd say she's more
schizophrenic than anything
half on my channel now about half of you
want to see me fail and half of you want
to see me succeed
no hold on i'm going to do something
right now
i want to
see you win at
life there
now she knows like i think we can make
her viral if we take this
mayo head thing and we go hey guys
let's all do the mayo head challenge
yes okay and then we all go get
the shittiest mail you can find don't
get the good stuff get the shitty stuff
because you got to be authentic and we
all well i mean you're
i guess you could wash your beard maybe
yeah yeah of course your head you're
bald
yeah um but i can do my beard yeah do
your beard we'll all we'll get merced to
do it maybe some hair will grow in the
front of his head after
you know treatment quite possibly um and
then we'll get everybody doing it we can
get even zen rhinos and rhino can do it
i know well hold on
he's bald doesn't have any hair either
does he have chest hair i never
i don't want no idea i don't want to
know i wouldn't want to know that never
mind uh
who has hair arnold nicotine has got a
beard he can do the mayo challenge yeah
arnold casino is [ __ ] too busy
screaming at hospital workers
yeah all right i've seen bali bali's got
hair
um who else has hair we're all old [ __ ]
that have no hair well
but the women could do it but the women
could do it like miami milf could do it
closure could do it
yeah and we'll just start the engine and
then it all
starts with her so she'll go famous yes
the mayo head challenge i really like
that
and we'll do it we'll do it like you
know how they're doing the eight the
challenge for
for adl that they were doing the water
bucket challenge
uh or als adl adl is [ __ ] something
completely different the ls challenge
we could do something like that but for
mayo would you have to pick a charity
like i don't know what what's a charity
we could pick
uh multiple personality disorders there
you go disassociated well that's
perfect so we're gonna do the male head
challenge for multiple personality
disorder we're gonna make it go viral or
it puts mayo in their head and then we
raise money for crazy people
i like it i think this is great i think
we can make this work
this is doing good for the world yeah
you know that's still over a hundred
people
that actively support me
but my brain can't wrap my it it can't
it can't understand
that like bali says i could put mustard
on my hair if that helps
sure why not and how can you not afford
like mayo the
mayo head can can do it yeah she's
homeless
yeah she even got the cheap [ __ ] that's
why i said get the cheap [ __ ]
don't waste dukes on your head come on
no of course not oh part of me knows
that there are a lot of you out there
hoping for me you know i hope for you
too well every day i still
feel like i'm i'm on my own
this one this one goes out to her yeah
there you go just for you
tastes like mayo that's a hope bowl
i am but i'm not
so i'm i'm really going to be trying
harder
um i'm going to be going back on the
gluten-free
as my as well miami milf is so bougie
she goes i don't even know where to buy
cheap mail
um you go to the dark zone uptown yeah
there you go
go to overtown mommy milf i can
you know um
i've been having a lot of issues with
just not eating at all
when i don't eat gluten because i just
i have trouble with food you know it's
it took me well the first indicator that
you had trouble with food is the fact
that you put mayonnaise in your head
yeah but not troubling the way you would
think exactly you're [ __ ] lathering
mayo in your [ __ ] head that's
that is trouble with food i will agree
it's kind of like airplane when he has a
drinking problem he just can't put
liquid in his mouth
probably about three hours to actually
finish that steak
last night just i cut it up and i was
picking at it
while i was drunk and if i wasn't drunk
i wouldn't have been able to eat that
much of it
because i just i don't eat i'm detecting
another problem that may be the reason
[Music]
so maybe you shouldn't buy so much cheap
wine
yeah cheap [ __ ] see that's her problem
she goes cheap if she went for the finer
things in life
mm-hmm you know she would be fancy
duke's mayo and fancy wine
yes good [ __ ] but anyways
that's what's going on right now um i'm
going to
i'm working on it but this time
double sunburn you put mayo in your head
and your rice to birds that's the
trouble you keep wasting it there it is
that is a problem with food i will agree
is especially hard for me with
that is a good question marie when does
steak have gluten
it doesn't but does rice have gluten i
think so
so i don't i don't know i don't know
what what i don't know if rice is gluten
i just eat the food my old lady makes it
does rice have gluten
all right you do that one i'll do steak
a gluten-free diet is only treatment for
the condition gluten is found grains
wheat
barley and rye does steak have gluten
you could eat rice you could eat rice
and potatoes it says yes
meat is naturally gluten free okay so
that answered that
there you go so she could eat rice
feeling alone and feeling like i deserve
pain and just
i apologize if my videos start getting a
little bit depressing
um i mean first off to imply that they
already weren't depressing to begin
with it's not like we it's not like we
started at a baseline
of not depressing videos and i know the
rest of them is just her catching
pokemon
you know um but man she makes a lot of
videos huh
she's a machine dude that's why i said
if she goes viral she's gonna [ __ ]
go crazy like well i mean all right
that's kind of putting in a little blunt
but
uh she's gonna she's gonna she's a
workhorse she's ready to go
this is weird but i think i'm sunburned
but i don't know
what is happening to my chest
from the drinking honey red and why does
it change colors when i press on it
am i dying that's not good maybe that
new crystal you got around your neck is
poisonous or something well that's the
old one
oh you're right you're right there's an
old video maybe that old crystal was
poisonous or something
i'm sorry i know enough about her to
tell the difference between her neck
of course you do jj of course you do i'm
too autistic for this
you can't catch me royce go ahead hang
up on me i'm just kidding
ha ha that one's mine jj that one was
mine
uh what's the tally now big guy